let's bring in retired 4 star general
jack keane fox news senior strategic
analyst and chairman of the institute
for the study of war general you've been
watching this minute by minute and the
newest information that we have really
is what just came from the american
president president biden who outlined
these sanctions against
against russia how powerful do you think
they are how is this perceived by putin
do you think
well certainly putin has made that
calculation dealing with sanctions we've
advertised for months
what we intend to do with sanctions and
he's war gamed all all of those
sanctions and
and i i don't think it's going to have
any deterrent effect on what he is
attempting to do in ukraine
um
if if if we felt that
these sanctions were going to have some
impact i would dial up all of them now
and then dial them back based on on him
dialing back his troops but he's he's
got a deliberate multi-phase
uh campaign plan that he's executing
it's now coming into focus
uh martha and we get a better sense of
it it is deliberate and he's going by
phases phase one
is put troops into the territories where
the russian separatists already control
those troops are there he denies it
there they're from the eighth combined
arms army
second phase he's already laid claim
today to the full
republics to two full republics
two-thirds of that territory is owned by
ukraine military and it's heavily
militarized
phase two would likely be
initiated by pre-assault fires air
missile rocket long-range artillery
and ground mechanized attack across the
line of contact simultaneously likely
into both
of those republics where the ukraine
forces are employed
phase three
probably a pause
and does he go into the rest of the
dombass region into eastern ukraine uh
marrow pool and down towards uh the land
bridge with crimea that's speculation
and then phase four is what we're all
talking about he has multiple options on
how to topple and put pressure on the
kiev government so i think these phases
are going to unfold they are they are
deliberate and sanctions are going to
have absolutely no impact
on the plan that putin is executing
would anything have an impact i mean you
know president biden had this moment to
speak moments ago i just want to play a
little bit of what he said and then i
want to ask you you know
what can be done really at this point
watch
who in the lord's name does putin think
gives him the right to declare
new so-called countries
on territory that belong to his
neighbors
this is a flagrant violation of
international law and demands a firm
response from the international
community so general we know that
president that putin doesn't see it that
way he detailed in great uh exhaustive
essay
all the reasons that he thinks ukraine
is part of russia he believes it always
has been and he blamed you know former
soviet leaders for giving it away it was
very i mean interesting from a historic
perspective but so you hear president
biden they're saying you know that it
won't stand essentially but but how do
you
what changes that
well putin really
has a vision here and he's revealed it a
couple of times once in the in the
missive that he wrote last july
in 2021 uh which he contributed to
significantly 5 000 words and so many
hour-long speech in the nfc meeting
yesterday and when i look at that when i
boil it down to simplicity
uh what what he's about he he's taking
the post-cold war boundaries and
reconstructing them
because he absolutely believes when the
coal when the soviet union collapsed the
united states led an expansion into
eastern europe with nato at the expense
of russia and their security and he
wants a new security arrangements and he
wants to address those boundaries and
that's his vision and he starts with
ukraine and belarus and acquiring both
of those under his orbit is formidable
and anybody that thinks he's not going
to pressure nato
if he carries out what i'm talking about
is misguided so i absolutely believe
that the president is right in
reinforcing the baltics i think we
should uh even put more troops into
poland than what we're doing we do have
an armored brigade there it's great to
see uh the paratroopers that
general petraeus and i have commanded we
have great great love for them but armor
mechanized forces in this fight is
really what makes a difference and we've
got to upgrade ourselves in these nato
countries so yes that's the right the
right move i would also keep the door
open for military aid
to ukraine uh and keep that flowing and
make certain if there's still things
that they desperately need now
let's stop the resistance that we've had
for a year and a half and not giving
them the things that are on their
shopping list that would truly help to
impose cost on putin some of that's
going to be too late because they they
don't have the time to train their
people on them it's more sophisticated
weaponry but there's other things that
we can certainly help them with
robert o'brien the former national
security adviser said he sees a scenario
where it's very difficult for zielinski
to hold onto power and he says that we
need to
support an insurgency and basically help
organize elections outside of ukraine
for expats and refugees and continue to
give them support
do you agree with that and do you think
that's feasible
well i i definitely agree with it and i
while putin certainly is his military
military's an over match for the
ukrainian military they will
and he he he can defeat them he'll never
defeat the ukrainian people i mean they
will resist
and fight to the last russian soldier
leaves that leaves their soil but listen
let's be honest about this i mean
putting together an insurgency campaign
with munitions
and
and weapons and capability
organization and the rest of it that
takes time we can assist with that putin
has also calculated that he's looked at
and he says he knows how tough the
ukrainians are he certainly understands
that better than we do but he's put that
into his calculation he knows that's
protracted and it'll have
marginal impact initially and maybe
long-term impact for certain and he's
he's accepted if he conducts the
full-out invasion
the cost of all of that as he has
accepted the cost of what he believes is
a tough sanction regime and you know
about the sanctions
he's he's experienced a history of it
they seem to diminish over time and the
country also gets used to them over time
so that's another factor
now the sanctions that we are talking
about imposing i'm not suggesting that
we don't do them i'm all in favor of
them i'm all in favor of hurting putin
significantly and taking down his
central banks and foreign investment
and also i believe dealing with his
industry sectors and certainly the
people involved i agree with all of it
he should pay a price it's just that i
don't believe sanctions are necessarily
the deterrents that people think they
are i think they serve a purpose in
dramatizing the scale of the
international violation that putin has
committed here and you get others to
contribute in that sanction regime and
then and very importantly
it's about punishment and retribution
for the scale of that violation those
things have to be done where it's a
moral imperative to do things like that
but don't kid ourselves to think that
somehow this is going to deter putin
from the objectives that he feels he
intends to achieve here in ukraine well
we know the white house has said that
diplomacy and deterrence were there are
two avenues for preventing this um it
seems that at least at this point
diplomacy has failed although the white
house says they're still open to any
potential diplomatic avenue the
deterrence uh you're saying is not going
to be
useful in terms of stopping the activity
that they're undertaking and who knows
how much further they are determined to
go just yeah go ahead one more point
martha
the biden administration threatened
serious sanctions
after an invasion and they used that
basic promise
to deter that invasion
we now have an invasion
so that strategic policy imperative
has failed that's just the simple facts
of it which i would point out you have
said all along uh on that even a strong
voice saying that nothing would deter
them unless it happened before
they went in and obviously they've
determined that
it's not going to be that punishing and
it's worth the gamble it's worth going
in and as you say these sanctions tend
to deter over time
or diminish over time because they
figure out ways to get around it and
countries get a little bit weaker on
getting stuff in there and wanting to
have that trade so we've seen that
happen over history as well general
thank you so much general jack keane who
will be with us throughout the course of
uh covering this story i think for some
time general thank you very much always
good to have you with us i'm steve ducey
i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainslie
earhart and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis